الطفل المعجزه في قبضه الشرطه بجزر
المهامز سام هو مؤسس بورصه العملات
المشفره المنهاره والتي تعرف اختصارا باكت
اكس اعتقل لارتكابه جرائم ماليه والاحتيال
الالكتروني عوده للشهر الماضي اف تي اكس
كانت قد تقدمت بطلب لاعلان افلاسها في
الولايات المتحده ما تسبب في عجز
المستخدمين عن سحب اموالهم الشركه التي
تاسست عام 2019 وكانت ثاني اكبر بورصه
تشفير في العالم مدينه اليوم بمبلغ يقدر
بنحو ثلاثه فاصله واحد مليار دولار لاكبر
50 دائم من عملاء الذي كان يعامل على انه
نموذج وقدوه للمستثمرين الامريكيين الشباب
انتهت قصته باسوا الشكل ممكن يواجه الحبس
لعقود المزيد معارك اسلام
بعدما كان امبراطور العملات المشفره
وعبقري الاسواق الماليه الجديده بين ليله
وضحاها تحطمت كل هذا على شواطئ المهاماس
سامو البنك من العمر 30 عاما اصبح منبوزا
بعدما واجهت شركته ازمه السيوله وتقدمت
بطلب لاعلان الافلاس ما يعني منعو حصول
مالا يقل عن مليون شخص من المذيعين على
اموالهم
السقوط المدوي من النعمه الى الافلاس اذهل
المستثمرين وعشاق العملات المشفره الذين
اشد ذات مره بالامريكي باعتباره المنقذه
لهذه الصناعه ولكن ما الذي حصل حقيقه
ليدفع بالرئيس التنفيذي السابق لشركه اف
تي اكس للعملات المشفره المنهار ان يتوجه
للعالم عبر تويتر يقول اعتذر لانني اخفقت
في الثاني من نوفمبر الماضي استشهد ما
قالوا استقصائي بوثيقه ماليه مسربه اثر
التساؤلات حول التعاملات اف تي اكس
والمخاطر العاليه التي تتخذها
اسس النظام البيئي باكمله
وتراجعت اسعار العملات الرقميه جميعها حيث
دفع المستثمرون للخروج من المراكز
المحفوفه بالمخاطر ونتيجه لذلك وفي حاله
من الزرار زرع المذيعون لسحب اموالهم من
العديد من منصات التشفير مما اجبر
المقردين على وقف عمليات السحب
الفارس الابيض لقطاع العملات المشفره
انتهى به الامر معتقلا وصناعه العملات
المشفره على حافه الهاويه في انتظار سقوط
قطعه دومينو التاليه بعد فتره وجيزه من
انهيار افتكس انخفضت قيمه المزيد من
العملات المشفره السائده مما في ذلك
البيتكوين والاسيريوم والصلانه
شاب غامض يبلغ من العمر 30 عاما تمكن من
شقي طريقه عبر دوائر يهيمن عليها المشاهير
والمشاريعون والمستثمرون الاثرياء
ظهر على اغلفه
تم ترحيب به على انه لن وفاه العملات
المشفره راكما سوى شخصيه هائله بلغت حوالي
26 مليون دولار في ذروتها في وقت سابقا
هذا العام ولكنه اليوم موقوف
وانتظاري محاكمه وصفت بالتاريخيه في
الاوساط الامريكيه السياسيه والماليه على
حد سواء لصباح
ريتا سليمان واشنطن
في فقره الجانب الاقتصادي تنضم الينا في
الاستوديو زميله سمر نشر الصحفيه في قسم
الاقتصاد سمر صباح الخير يسعد صباحك ما
حقيقه ما حصل باكمان متوها من الموجهه
اليه وكم سنه سيسجن في هذه الحاله مبدئيا
هناك البارحه يعني يوجهوا الى ثمان تهم
واحده منهم غسيل اموال في منهم التامر على
البورصه واوراق البورصه الماليه في عندك
احتلال تامر همم الغش او ايضا يعني هم
كمان تقريبا
حسب حالات صارت سابقا همم نفس الشيء من
احد البورصات ال- همم الكريبتون سجن السي
اوه عشر سنوات بس هو متراكمه عليه العديد
اضافه الى اختلاف الاموال وغيرها ممكن
نتوصل 25 همم سنه همم يعني مؤبد الحكم
عليه هلا هو يقول 25 ممكن يوصل 25 مؤبد
لانه مواجهتها هو يقول انه هو ما قصد يسوي
اي من هذه الاخطاء ان هي لم تكن احتيال هو
مجرد صار خطا وتلاعب غير مقصود بس خطا
يعني هيكسر يقبض عليه اذا كان السيد لي
بشهادته امام القضاء كان المفروض يدلي
بشهادته امام القضاء هناك العديد من
علامات التساؤل انه ليش انقبضوا عليه قبل
ان يدلي بشهادته همم تشير الشائعات والقصص
على الكثير مو شائعاتها حقيقه موجوده على
الكثير من الاعلام وسائل الاعلام اليوم
انه هو دعم الحزب الديمقراطي الامريكي
بسته همم مليارات دولار وايضا هنا
مشفره وبعدين طبعا
العديد من الحملات ودعم العديد من يعني
الاعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ فهما قال انه قد
يكون يحاولوا التكتم على شيء معين لهذا
قبضه وعليه لانه هذه المشاكل او هذا نوع
من القضايا ما يطلع فيها حكم رقصا كده في
يوم وليله تاخذ سته اشهر او اكثر هو ما
صار لها من 15 يعني القضايا المماثله اخذت
اكثر من 6 اشهر لا يتم القبض فعليا قبل
الادلاء بشاهدته هو مسكوه بليله قبل
الادلاء من من شهادته فيثير العديد منه
متورط معه بعد في هذه ما حصل مع سامبل بان
كيف يمكن يؤثر على العملات المشفره
مبدئيا فقدت هذا العام يعني غير اللي صار
مع حسام فقدت مبدايا واحد فاصل اربعه
تريليون دولار من قيمتها خلال هذا العام
اتت العديد من هذه الخسائر في شهر نوفمبر
بعد قصه همم منصه
البارحه مثلا
في السوق وفي الاشخاص همم مستثمرين في هذه
العملات البارحه مثلا
تم سحب او تكييف يعني تسيير العملات مشفره
بسته مليارات دول عربي 24 ساعه مضطر منصه
اللي هي اكبر من السطر
اللي هي اصلا اساس المشكله اللي افتي اكس
لان خلطه انسحبت من شراء اف تي اكس فسبب
المشكله كلها تاريخ طويل يعني ابعدلها
اكيد قاعده لحالها فهي هاي البارحه باينه
مجرد باينه صار توقف على عمليات التداول
بسبب هلع المستهلكين وحاولوا يسحبوا
المزيد من الاموال اها طيب سمر هل هذا
يعني لا استثمار حاليا في العملات المشفره
ام لا استسلام بعد الذي حصل مع سامي انا
لا استطيع ان ادعي برايي تم تنبيه المراه
الماضيه لانه احنا كسحفيين ممنوع احنا
نوجه همم السوق باي طريقه
هناك مقسومه نصين يعني في ناس مع العملات
المشفره ويقول لك هذا همم المستقبل
بالنهايه انه الا ما يصير دي سنترالزيشن
او لا مركزيه بالنسبه للعملات المشفره اذا
مش الحين بعد عشر سنين واليوم اللي بس
تكون امبارح بلشت شويه تطلع مره اخرى مع
تراجع اسعار النف بس وارتفاع التضخم بس
بنفس الوقت هناك اشخاص يقول لك هاي مبنيه
على لا شيء على هواء على اي اساس انت يعني
او شفت شلون انهارت اليوم فحقيقه يعني هاي
مختلفه بعدها يبين ويانا ان شاء الله خلال
السنوات القادمه يا رب شكرا شكرا